mental health professionals who worked
at the Tavistock who undertook these
assessments who referred some of those
young people that they themselves fear
that they've been part of a Major
Medical
School some people say there was
pressure to to refer quickly because it
freed up their time as clinicians
because the waiting list was growing and
once you referred a young person to
Endocrinology you saw them less
frequently so it freed up some clinical
time we into I mean
that's horrifying yeah anyway
perhaps you get to the point that you
can't you can't change direction because
what does that mean what does that mean
for you as a human being to go oh my God
I might have
got this wrong and I might have got it
wrong for some of the most vulnerable
young people there are how do we get
from
a handful to thousands that's the 64
million dollar question isn't it if I'm
an ordinary person watching this based
on every time we've gone down one of
these
cul-de-sacs we always end up with there
was not enough data they stopped
collecting it I'm thinking cover-up
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine kitten and this is a show
for you if you want honest conversations
with Fascinating People our terrific
guest today is an author and
journalist's latest book called time to
think is about the demise of the
Tavistock gender Clinic here in the UK
Hannah Barnes welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me oh it's a pleasure
we've been trying to make this happen
for a while we had covered you had
covered it didn't happen here you are
finally before we get into your book
it's a very important book uh who are
you how are you where you are what has
been the journey through life that leads
you to be here sitting talking to us
it's only through life well I
I've been a journalist at the BBC for 15
years before that I worked in commercial
radio it's a news reader and uh reporter
I'm a mum of two kids young kids
um I grew up in the suburbs of London I
had a pretty normal childhood
I
went to Oxford and did the degree of
politicians PPE and obviously by most
people's standards I'm a massive failure
because I'm not prime minister
um and they went into journalism from
there
and you mentioned your BBC journalist
you I saw you a couple of days ago at
Newsnet actually
um but uh if I if I may say I hope it's
not an unfair representation but I feel
like the issue of uh transgenderism and
some of the issues to do with trans
ideology and so on it sort of was the
coverage of that was led from the new
media and and older media took some time
to get there I don't know if that's a
fair characterization do you
um you don't agree
I would agree and disagree so I think
um
I think at Newsnight we were really
ahead of the curve and actually much of
the stuff that we know is because of the
reporting that I did with my former
colleague Deb Cohen so you know we
started doing that in 2019 and at that
point there really wasn't much around
there was we were doing it in 2018 but
yeah sure
but you know Janice Turner was writing
in the times and there was some stuff in
print media but I think it wasn't really
till
uh you know I think our reporting
directly led the CQC to inspect the
gender identity development service at
the Tavistock
um
I I think we we did have a big impact oh
sorry I feel like I've opened the
interview by what appears it was me
having a massive go at you even though
you're one of the people that's done
well where I was trying to get to is why
do you think unlike you that's maybe the
way I should have phrased it many people
took a long time to get to this point
where this conversation was even being
had
because I think the media just reflects
all these other organizations that have
taken a huge amount of time to get to
the point that we're at today so you
know you could clock you could lamp
politicians in with that The Regulators
the NHS the central NHS I mean the way
that several clinicians at the Tavistock
put it to me was that
this word gender in some way muddied the
waters and sort of the usual checks and
balances if you like that you'd expect
in medicine and particularly when you're
caring for children and young people
just weren't there people were
frightened that in some way asking the
same questions or raising the same
concerns that you would in any other
part of
caring for young people when you did
that in this space there was a fear of
being branded transphobic whereas
actually all they were saying was we're
not sure this is safe
and
you know another said everybody assumed
that we knew what we were doing that we
were the Specialists and somehow
it must be really complicated and there
was this cloak of mystery so
that's the only explanation that I think
potentially explains why so many people
looked away for so long and as Hillary
Cass has said this hasn't been subject
to the normal oversight you'd expect
especially when we're talking about
children and
drugs that are being used off label
about which we don't know the long-term
impact and before we get into the book
what the question that I already asked
you is what motivated you to write this
book what motivated you to go into the
eye of the storm and it is a storm and
it is possibly the most toxic issue of
our time
well I got to the point that we'd done
sort of four films at newsnite we also
did a radio documentary
and
but with all always with journalism
there's so much more that you know that
you can never put on screen I mean not
at all that we were blocked in any way
we're enormously supported by by
newsnite
but I knew so much more and
you know I've lost sleep over it and I
was really worried by some of the stuff
I heard and I just thought
this is a story that has to be told
Because unless this is in the public
domain we can't have a
adult calm evidence-based discussion
about how best to care for this group of
often very vulnerable children and young
people I didn't think it was my job to
provide answers I don't think that I'm
not a campaigning journalist I I felt
there needed to be a lasting record of
what has happened because I think it's
undeniable things have gone wrong some
things have gone well as well
and
some conditions not all wanted their
story
told and they this conversation had to
come out of the gender clinics and into
wider Society because the welfare of
children really is kind of everyone's
business I agree with you and what were
the things that you lost sleep over
Hannah
well that potentially
very vulnerable children might have been
harmed
and
you know documents from the clinic
transcripts of interviews that Jed's
clinicians gave to the medical director
in well across 2018
they were deeply upsetting
those clinicians talked about the young
people they were seeing not all of them
but some being
some of the most vulnerable children
they've ever seen and being in really
quite a terrible State and in some cases
and again not
very many but in some cases they were
referred for quite a major physical
intervention after an hour or two or
even three or four which was allowed but
the levels of
trauma that some of those children had
suffered prior to that that didn't seem
to be being explored It's upsetting you
know and I
became a mom in 2016 and it just changes
your outlook I suppose of course it does
I mean when we you say major
interventions because there's going to
be people who are listening to this who
won't know what that means and you were
talking about major trauma so let's
explore a little bit what those terms
mean what does it mean major trauma and
what do major interventions mean so
trauma so some of these young people
had
suffered physical or sexual abuse
some had lost a parent very young
through bereavement or you know had
suffered family breakdown as
a small but sizable proportion we're
living in care which
sort of implies that there's been the
difficult circumstances leading up to
that some were living in quite a risky
way in terms of their sexual behavior
um those are all traumatic some had
parents that were abusing alcohol or
drugs or who had mental breakdown and
that's not
those parents fault but that's quite
traumatic for a child to grow up in that
living environment as well so
all those kind of things that would put
together in a broad
umbrella under trauma in terms of major
interventions
I mean people will dispute this but
I'm talking about the first intervention
and sort of the primary one that jeds
would refer to would refer young people
for is colloquially puberty blockers
and
it would seem from the very poor but
in limited data that we have that once
on puberty blockers the vast vast
majority of those young people would
then go on to hormones so either
synthetic testosterone or estrogen
depending on your
sex and
you know with with those came lots of
physical
um potential risks particularly
if you block puberty early and you go
straight onto hormones
you will be sterile for example
um
not so much if you if you go on later
then there's chances to preserve
fertility but
you know all sorts of things and to
even those who are very happy as trans
adults and
for them it was the right and only path
they will tell you that it's not always
easy living as a trans man or woman you
have to take medication for the rest of
your life if you medically transition
you may have
several intrusive surgeries so to go
through that and it not be the right
path
is is
awful and Hannah I want to go back to
the the core of this issue with the
Tavistock and for you to explain a
little bit more at a more basic level
for people who we've got a big audience
around the world but before we do uh
there is a uh and forgive me for asking
this question but I actually do think
it's important
um the way you talk about it there's a I
feel like there's a tension within you
because another one on the one hand I
think you want to communicate about
these issues that you truly care about
on the other hand I think you'll you
feel like you have to be very careful uh
as well or maybe I'm imposing that on
you I don't know the reason I'm asking
this is it feels to me like if 20 years
ago
a story had come out about some children
being harmed by medical malpractice a
journalist at BBC News night would be
like this is the biggest story I'm gonna
get the scoop I'm gonna go out and
uncover this which you've done I don't
know that they would have had the same
sort of
um feeling that this is a landmine issue
why is that why is it medical
malpractice on children an issue of
which about which you have to be so
careful
I think there's there's lots of
different aspects to what you've said
there so
I think
well generally when you're talking about
medical malpractice as you put it it's a
question of you know a botched medical
procedure isn't it but what's Happening
Here is it's it's so intertwined with
someone's sense of themselves an
identity and I don't think you have that
in other
um
stories
now
I am cautious because
I think you know there are lots of
people out there commenting on this so
and and do so probably in much stronger
terms than I do but what I've done and
why I think the book has been received
so well
is I'm not telling people what to think
I've laid out the evidence and
everything you know I think there's 70
pages of references in the best way that
I can in the fairest way I can and for
people then to make up their own minds
because partly because I work for the
BBC and we're absolutely committed to
impartiality but I just think
there are lots of people out there who
will Express their opinions and
I think actually what so many people
have said to me from reading the book is
I just never knew any of this and it's
trying to be calm
and I think I don't talk about it in the
same way I would as you say you know
another medical Scandal because I
actually think the only honest thing to
say is that we don't really know the
scale at the moment
so I would say what do we know we know
that we know that some young people have
been harmed and I've spoken to them and
their stories are in the book and we
know that other young people
appear to have been helped they say
they've been helped and they're happy
we don't know what the numbers are
either way and those will undoubtedly
change over time
so I think it's really
hard to say
well I you know that's why I'm reluctant
to say
this is a major medical Scandal it may
well be at the moment I just don't think
we have enough data to put any sense of
scale on it but what I think and what I
felt was so striking is that
mental health professionals who worked
at the Tavistock who undertook these
assessments who referred some of those
young people that they themselves fear
that they've been part of a major
medical scandal
and let's talk about the medical Scandal
I I feel bad because it feels like I've
been grilling you about your own
personal opinions but I the reason I
I've asked you about it is I think it
kind of shows you how Society is around
this issue and it's telling I think uh
but anyway let's not delve too far into
that
um so I mean like you're right I think
but I think I think it's good to be
cautious about language as well because
actually I think sometimes we forget
that we are talking about children and
young people and I think sometimes the
language is really unfortunate
um
and and actually different people like
different terms and what have you but I
I just think it's important to have some
compassion as well oh 100 yeah 100 but I
suppose the argument might be that if
you recognize the damage that's being
done then the compassionate thing to do
is to scream about it from every rooftop
some people would argue too and and
that's the debate I think uh I think
you've done a great job of actually
laying out the fact so
um let's talk about the fact the
Tavistock was uh shut uh was a clinic
here in the UK and give us some of the
numbers what sort of numbers are we
talking about how many people were
coming through how many people would
have been referred for puberty blockers
what other things did you find that sort
of people should know about
well in the early days so that the the
the the unit the
gender identity development unit as it
originally was started off at another
London Hospital in South London St
George's and I think the first year two
children were referred
it moves to the Tavistock and Portland
NHS Foundation trust in the mid 90s
um and it still was about a dozen a year
it grows
it you know it ticks up and then fast
forward to 2009 we've got 97 referrals
2019 another decade and we've got two
and a half thousand
and last the last year we have numbers
Force which is 2122 more than five
thousand
so we've had quite a
big increase yeah I'd say so you know
you look at it it's that classic hockey
stick
graph
um and from 2009 to 15
the referrals go up at 50 per annum and
then in 2015-16 they double
and at the same time you have this
really quite radical shift in the
demographics of the young people being
referred so initially
the majority of those referred were boys
ah birth registered males assigned males
whatever language you want to use
um
2011 there's parity equal number of boys
and girls referred and then by 2015
total reversal and now we've got
two-thirds of the referrals girls but
not just
girls but girls who actually
their gender distress only started in
adolescence after the onset of puberty
which was completely different to the
traditional presentation if you like
which was sort of lifelong since early
childhood
gender incongruence and lots of these
girls not all of them but lots had
really quite serious and
distressing other difficulties that they
were also contending with so no one
doubted that they were distressed about
their gender but loads them had
other Associated difficulties as well
like anxiety depression perhaps they
were self-harming eating disorders maybe
they'd had a traumatic child all these
things
um in terms of how many were referred
for puberty blockers
we don't know because every time
someone has asked either the Tavistock
and Portman or one of the two trusts
that
prescribe the puberty blockers so at the
University College London hospitals or
Leeds teaching hospitals they've not
provided an answer
so best estimates
from what is in the public domain
at least 1500 I would say I mean a
freedom of information request said that
by 2017 there'd been over 1200 so I
don't think it's unreasonable to think
we're in excess of 1500 but the answer
is we don't know and I think that's one
of the things that is so
striking about this story is the lack of
data and how a clinic that's been
running now for close to 35 years is
really not able
to tell the public at least
really
anything meaningful about the thousands
of young people that they've seen that's
shocking the fact that they had didn't
even keep records what is either one or
two things they either didn't keep the
record or the refusing to disclose them
I don't know which is worse yeah either
of those two options uh I mean that's
horrific well this is the thing that's
that has really sort of
shocked clinicians as well who worked
there because they say well look we had
a research team we collected loads and
loads of data so where is it now as you
say it's either there but not somehow
collatable in a meaningful way or
they collected the wrong data you know
stuff that doesn't matter I don't know
but we don't know it and for example in
one one example of this is that um
um
feet for years they said 40 of young
people referred to us are then referred
on to for puberty blockers subsequently
that's come down but they were
consistent about that for many many
years in the press and everything like
that
they put this figure in an academic
paper and then they explained where
where it had come from
um
and
the tavistot were asked well
through Freedom of Information
could could they give the actual numbers
behind this this graph which which put
age of referral and the proportion of
which had gone on to endocrinology
and they said no we don't have it the
lead author is a professional at uclh
asked them and the person that did the
number crunching if you like doesn't
doesn't work here they were a research
doctoral assistant
so uclh were asked that same question
you've got this graph can we just have
the data behind it
we don't have it please go back to the
tether store
now the Tavistock then said
we've done a search and we don't have it
now
one of several things is true then
either
they do have the those numbers
but don't want to release them for for
whatever reason
or they don't have them and and it's
like well what does that what does that
tell you so this is their core
treatment pathway referral
of young people for puberty blockers
they have this really quite important
data
their data
but they've not kept it
and they've not continued that either
it's I mean it's baffling I don't I
don't know which of those is true but
either way
it would be helpful to know
that's such a British way of putting the
most BBC way of putting it uh Hannah so
thousands of young people are referred
to this Clinic
can you describe to us as a kind of as a
customer of this thing or whatever the
right term is there's a patient whatever
it is what is your experience like so
you're a child let's say you're I don't
know what what were they what would be a
sort of median age
11 12 13. so you're 11 12. you may be
coming from care you may be coming from
a dysfunctional family you may have been
abused you get there
what happens to you
I'll answer that I just wanted to stress
not all kids were like that yeah and I
just want to say like so many of the
these young people actually you know
they had loving families and they just
didn't know what to do there's nothing
worse than seeing your children in pain
so uh
and they were going to the professionals
to ask for help well quite and as a
parent I think actually you know this is
sometimes where people go why do why do
people care so much about this issue
it's not that many people and whatever
but you mentioned yourself becoming a
mother and as a parent now myself I
think for a lot of parents their big
fear is that a and we'll we'll get on to
this where do young people particularly
young girls get the idea that this is
the right thing for them number one
let's say your child has that and then
you go to the professionals and you're
like look I'm just a parent I don't know
what's going on can you please help me
and then after a couple of hours they're
on the pathway to hell right that's I
think where parents concerns are so but
but tell me more so let's say so you're
so any given Young Person's experience
to be frank will be completely different
depending on who you and your family
happen to be
assigned to like which which pair of
clinicians you see that's reassuring and
this is part of the part of the
difficulty and something that was
absolutely highlighted by Hillary Cass
and by the CQC when they inspected jids
so on the one hand you had assessments
that could be and the CQC found this
let's say two appointments so it's two
hours
on another hand at the absolute extreme
there could be 50 sessions so that's
therefore you're talking years in the
latter a couple of hours in the format
now the experience that that young
person in their family have is so Worlds
Apart in those two things now it could
have been in the 50 session assessment
which is rare
was rare
it could be that that person was then
referred for puberty blockers but having
gone through years of talking therapy
and everybody being assured as they
could be because there's never certainty
but as sure as they could be and fully
informed and making that decision along
with their professionals
that is a very different kind of
relationship and
uh
you know
care offering than than the young person
who's seen two three four times
and so this was part of the difficulty
and
there was no agreement amongst the staff
group about how best to care for these
young people and I think this is really
important to stress that actually
globally there is not clinical agreement
on how to best care for this group of
young people and that might mean and it
probably does mean
there won't be one way either it might
well be that what works for some just
won't work for others because kids are
different
and just as there are different ways
that someone might get to their gender
dysphoria or gender incongruence there's
probably going to be different ways out
of it as well
so there is disagreement amongst people
even that working in gender clinics
today about how we best do this
but
fundamentally that makes the service
really difficult
um because
you know there was no agreement on what
what it was that they were treating in
the loosest possible sense you know not
to not to pathologize these these young
people but if you can't agree on what it
is
you're treating and how best to treat it
how can there ever be a sort of
consistent assessment and consistent
care and there wasn't if you believe
that
gender dysphoria equals being trans and
therefore that and that is a stable
lifelong identity then of course you
would refer for physical interventions
if you believe that actually gender
dysphoria might lead to a trans outcome
but equally it might be
um related to something else that's
causing you distress in your life then
you might not or you'd be far more
cautious about doing that and and that
was the difficulty I mean I was really
struck by
there's there was a clinician who's
who's in the book um Dr Kirsty Entwistle
who worked up in the Leeds site for jids
which doesn't really get a huge amount
of attention and she's very worried
pretty much as soon as she joins
and she has a massive difference of
opinion with the clinician that she's
working with about a couple of cases
now the solution
of the managers of the Leeds Jude's site
is that
Kirsty Entwistle and this other
clinician just won't ever work together
again
um
and
one of their
colleagues told me well that was the
only sensible solution because they were
so poles apart that they couldn't work
with families now what are the
implications of that do you have two
people working in the same NHS service
whose views are so opposed
and their opinions on how to care for
the patients that they can't work
together
it's quite extraordinary
so it's a very long-winded answer
because so it depends who you saw it
depends who you saw however I take it
from what you're saying is there was
variation in how different patients were
treated and some would have had a long
time to think about and go through the
process but I also take it that there
were some people who who would have
turned up had a couple of sessions and
onto the puberty block as they went is
that yeah correct yeah
and and how did that happen exactly that
why was that why was that allowed
well I think
in the earlier years so puberty blockers
became available
as sort of standardized practice at
these younger ages from 2014 after
they'd well they hadn't really completed
but after an initial attempt at a study
and at that stage 2014-15
although some of the clinicians didn't
understand perhaps why you might refer
even after six sessions which was the
kind of the assessment model they didn't
they weren't overly concerned because
in their eyes at that time what they
were constantly being told and there was
nothing to suggest to the contrary was
that what the puberty blockers did was
they provided time to think
and there were no long-term effects
um and they were completely reversible
and actually what so many of those young
people needed was time to think they
were very very distressed and the
rationale of the blocker makes perfect
sense
that you'll just you've got this
mismatch between your biological sex and
the gender identity that you
you know that you perceive
um you stop your body going through the
puberty of your biological sex and then
you can hopefully take away some of that
distress and then think about things
now
it was only really when so so in those
years 2015 ish
lots of clinicians told me that
pretty much any young person that wanted
the blocker
could have it during quite a quick
assessment and actually as long as they
met the criteria for gender dysphoria
which pretty much all of them did
because they're silly and most teenagers
would meet them
they would be referred for puberty
blockers what were the criteria for
gender dysphoria that you say were Silly
well
this is a
this is a rare moment of agreement from
both those who are very pro-medical
intervention and those who are very
against is that that you know they're
steeped in gender stereotypes so it'd be
things like
playing with toys that are typically
associated with the opposite sex having
friends that are mostly of the opposite
sex
um wanting to be
the opposite you know they're just
so if I were a girl who was a bit of a
tomboy yeah quote unquote and I felt
some sort of distress puberty blockers
off you go well yeah you have to have
the distress and it has to be for more
than six months but six months is is not
a huge amount of time no it's not a huge
amount of time
um and actually
the the the
small amount of data that we do have
kind of bears out that in those years of
2014 15 16.
a lot of people well proportionally lots
of people were referred like this data
that I mentioned before that
they didn't release because apparently
no one has it but there's a graph it's
the only graph in the book and it
actually shows that you know of those
who were referred in adolescence the
majority went on to be referred for
puberty blockers and the peak is at
about 14 and I turned into absolute Uber
geek and I actually blew this thing up
and I'm measuring it and I'm like oh one
millimeter is this and so I do actually
get their numbers and it's about 70 of
14 year olds during this particular time
period
and now you get an average of
a minority 40 because
the the really young ones obviously
aren't eligible to be referred and so
it's the classic the average the main
the mean is meaningless because it hides
what's going on in the middle so there
was that that they didn't think it made
sense
there was also the fact that
some people say there was pressure to to
refer quickly because it freed up their
time as clinicians because the waiting
list was growing
as we've already mentioned the referrals
were going through the roof they
breached their 18-week waiting uh Target
for the first time in sort of autumn
2015 and they never met it again
and once you refer to young person to
Endocrinology you saw them less
frequently
so it click it freed up some clinical
time
Hannah we interview I mean
that's horrifying yeah anyway
hey Francis do you like side hustles who
told you about that process it's an ad I
told you never to mention that in public
I avoided jail time it was only for a
bit well people all over the world are
starting a side hustle and they're
hearing this sound
sound of kitchen the only sound I heard
was sirens this is a British claw system
trying to keep an honest man down no
Francis the sound of another sale on
Shopify the all-in-one Commerce platform
to start run and grow your business come
on Francis play along otherwise you
won't meet the conditions of your parole
Shopify is a Commerce platform
revolutionizing millions of businesses
worldwide whether you're selling jewelry
or jigsaw puzzles Shopify simplify
selling online and in person so you can
successfully grow your business it
covers all your sales channels from the
shopfront ready point of sale system to
its all-in-one e-commerce platform
Shopify even gets you selling across
social media marketplaces like Facebook
Instagram and Tech talk it's full of
industry-leading tools ready to ignite
your growth Shopify gives you complete
control over your business and your
brand without learning new skills in
design or coding and thanks to 24 7 help
and with an extensive Business course
Library Shopify will be there with you
every step of the way just like the
Metropolitan Police with Francis I'm
ignoring that it's time to get serious
about selling and get Shopify today sign
up for a one pound per month trial
period at Shopify dot Co dot UK slash
Trigger or lowercase go to Shopify dot
Co dot UK slash trigger to take your
business to the next level today that's
Shopify dot Co dot UK slash trigger
Hannah we interviewed Marcus Evans who
was one of the whistleblowers on the
show two years ago and he said something
to on that interview which has always
stuck with me which he was said that
some of the people who were working at
the Tavistock were motivated more by
ideology than patient care
was that your experience when you were
doing your studies and you were actually
looking into this case or did you find
something else
I think it's a bit
a bit complicated than
putting it that way in my view
I don't think that the majority of
people that worked at jids were
ideologues they were just hard-working
caring
professionals who wanted to help kids
like the vast majority
and that's why and they became concerned
when the reality didn't really match the
theory if you like
where I think ideology really impacted
on jids is that there seemed to be this
inability to stand up to some of the
trans Charities and groups and
you know it was it was lobbying in part
not totally absolutely not but pressure
from those groups that helped
uh lower the age at which puberty
blockers could be available in the first
place there was a real big push for that
but there was pressure from from
elsewhere too and in the medical
community
but I think there was there was this
almost clinicians have described to me
there was this fear of
sort of upsetting those groups groups
like
mermaids which people have probably
heard of and and gyres and
that when data became available that
that challenged what they thought they
knew and that perhaps showed that
actually
puberty blockers weren't working in the
way they thought and had been telling
families
they didn't change direction
and
some people told me some clinicians told
me that they felt that that was because
there was a fear of how some of the
groups might respond and similarly you
know as more information came out
nothing nothing was codified nothing was
written down so in all fairness to some
of these clinicians who didn't pass on
information you could only pass on
something that you you know you can't
pass on what you don't know and
you know there's a there's a meeting in
the book and it was an absolute turning
point for lots of people but they have a
a visit that did staff have a visit from
a surgeon who performs vaginoplasties on
trans women so taking a penis and
surgically constructing a vagina and he
tells the jid staff he said look there's
a problem if you block puberty too early
in males there isn't enough
penile tissue
to to do that surgery in the safest and
most effective way
um you can still do it but it's riskier
and you know it you might have to have
subsequent surgery
to everybody listening to that that I
spoke to they from that moment on pass
that on to all of the relevant families
so no one questions that but it was
never written down despite the efforts
of one clinician who wrote a leaflet had
it approved by that surgeon and one of
the members of the leadership but it was
never signed off
so I spoke to clinicians who joined the
service subsequent to that so that was
in 2016. who never knew that so they
couldn't pass it on
and I'm told by people who work in Adult
Services that you can see that in some
notes that some trans women who
know when they were boys and looking to
transition were not told that when they
started the blocker and some were but
again it's it's this Lottery
so to go back to your question I don't
think
most of the people working there were
ideologues
um
I think there was a but I think
the service became if not captured then
frightened to stand up to ideology when
evidence became available that showed
actually this intervention was not
working for some people so effectively
these Charities and pushback if you
think my language is too inflammatory
but I'm trying to be as accurate as I
possibly can be these clinics were
essentially bullied by these charities
because they were intimidated by what
could happen or how essentially if they
didn't adhere to what these Charities
felt was best and as a result of that
patient care was compromised I'm not
sure I'd say they were bullied because
in all fairness to
Charities and Lobby groups that's what
they're there for right they're there to
to put forward their View
of what they feel is the best treatment
for the people they represent so I like
you can't you can't you can't blame them
why they didn't stand up to them I don't
know what's the worst that could have
happened these are all hypothetical
questions I mean it's but it it's
striking I think I think it's very
easy to understand why
um the medical pathway was introduced
and and why the age was lowered
originally and why they wanted to do
more research I think it's much harder
to understand why
there was no change in direction or at
least pausing to reflect when data came
back which suggested their original
assumptions were not the case
so that being the case we have this
situation which is awful absolutely
awful
when was the moment that the medical
community and people like Marcus Evans
started to go
there's something very wrong going on
here
people at different times so Marcus is
married to sue Evans who was the first
whistleblower if you like
um and she had concerns as far back as
2005 that that some young people were
being referred to quickly and bearing in
mind you had to be 16 at that point but
she
you know she saw some colleagues refer
young people after four appointments and
she felt that was too quick in in all
cases
um so Marcus Evans had
lived through that experience if you
like and then there was a sort of a
quite a big gap between Sue leaving in
around 2007 and then
uh
lots of people taking their concerns to
Dr David Bell who was a very senior
psychiatrist in the adult service of the
Tavistock but also at that time
the staff Governor so he was the
representative On The Board of Governors
who kind of spoke for staff across the
trust
and essentially 10 members of jid staff
who had tried repeatedly and there's a
paper trail that shows this to raise
their concerns with njids and within the
trust
to very very senior board members
nothing changed and so they took the
concerns to David Bell and then it all
became in the public and and that's when
Marcus
you know he resigned over the fact that
he didn't feel that those concerns were
being taken seriously Enough by by the
trust and and equally that Dr Bell had
been treated very poorly
um
but the clinicians themselves who are
working at that point
that I mean they each had different
moments but there was several it was
really when the first bit of data came
back from this study that had begun
which challenged all the assumptions
they had about puberty blockers because
what they showed was that
of those who had
become old enough by that point every
single one of them
had gone from the puberty blocker to
cross-sex hormones
but also
that there'd been no psychological
benefit to being on the puberty blocker
and so
for Dr Anna Hutchinson
she describes learning that as her holy
moment because it exploded
everything that they were doing she said
you know what are the chances of being
given time to think and all children and
young people thinking the same way she's
like that just doesn't happen it doesn't
happen in Psychology and also even if
we gave them time to that this is what
they did do there was no space to think
in the Tavistock model anyway in the
jits model because when you went on the
blocker you didn't have more talking you
had less
you got seen every three to six months
and so
and actually
these young people weren't feeling
better in some cases both
psychologically and physically they were
getting worse
and so at that point
quite a sizable number of collisions
just went
this isn't safe what we're doing
and they became much more cautious and
they extended their assessments and
that's probably how we got to you know
the 50 although very rare but you know
because they felt
as as one clinician puts it to me in the
book like
that knowledge that pretty much
everybody that started the block went on
to cross-sex hormones
totally changed the way I practiced
because if I didn't think that a young
person should go on hormones I wasn't
going to put them on the blocker
because you had to do the work then it
was far too late once they were on the
blocker because the other thing that
they noticed was that actually
a young person tended to
shut down once they got on the
medication they've got what they wanted
they weren't at all open to
talking Hannah and I'm curious about
what happened uh when prior to that
Discovery when people went and raised
concerns and they were not taken
seriously do we have a sense of why that
happened because I think that's a
question a lot of people would be asking
and I think you've got a very measured
take on all of this and that you're
really looking at an organization like
any organization which is lots of busy
people and they don't have the time and
blah blah blah blah is that what
happened was there was there people at
the board level who felt that this this
is the path that we they must proceed
down why did those concerns not get
taken seriously prior to this discovery
I think there are different reasons why
these concerns weren't acted on
one appears to be
that certain people in the trust
just believed that this was
the right thing to do like this is a
vulnerable group of young people trans
people
are marginalized and stigmatized and
we're helping them and any concern
is transphobic
I think
some people perhaps didn't raise
concerns as robustly as they might have
in hindsight because there was this
really
I don't know how unique it is but I
wouldn't say existed in the BBC for
example I mean I like my colleagues but
people at jid's describe it as a family
and they were encouraged to think that
way at least for a time when before it
became absolutely enormous
and
when concerns were raised about clinical
practice
it was
made to appear to the rest of the team
that you were criticizing the leadership
or you were criticizing a person and yet
these were people that we cared about
and you know you don't criticize your
family and then arguments would come
back well we're doing it better than
everybody else or you know the private
sector would be worse and they said but
that's not good enough
like what we're doing is not good enough
we can't just say well other people
would be worse
um some people have suggested that the
concerns weren't taken seriously enough
because over time the contribution that
Jed's made to the overall income of the
trust
was quite significant
so it it went from an around 2015 being
about five percent of income that came
into the trust to about 13 at its peak
and when you combined that with the
adult service which the Tavis Doctor Con
2017-18 it was a quarter of the entire
income and no one suggested that there
was anything sort of really malicious
about that
but
so many people just said it had to be a
factor even unconsciously
that there was so much
um you know the the financials
stability and viability of the trust
depended on this income
Dr David Bell said to me perhaps it
wasn't taken seriously because
to really listen to what those
clinicians were saying you couldn't put
a sticky plaster on it you had to it
just required a complete overhaul a
radical rethink of exactly what they
were doing
um but hold on a second Hannah these are
kids lives that are being
irreversibly damaged that their bodies
and and I'm not saying obviously you but
they're putting the system ahead of that
that to me is it's apparent
but as I say I don't think anyone no one
has suggested to me that that
I don't think anyone
is was intentionally harming children I
mean agreed I don't think there's any
evidence for that have children been
harmed yes they have so
and I think
what's so interesting about the people
that spoke to me for the book and put
their names on record is that it's very
rare for us as human beings to say do
you know what I've done something really
wrong yeah that's true and
and they did do that and
Anna Hutchinson puts it you know why
weren't the concerns taken seriously
she says it might be that those people
at the top of the service who have been
there four years well over a decade
referring young people for puberty
blockers
perhaps you get to the point that you
can't you can't change direction because
what does that mean what does that mean
for you as a human being to go oh my God
I might have
got this wrong and I might have got it
wrong for some of the most vulnerable
young people
there are and perhaps that's intolerable
and perhaps that explains in part why
they didn't change direction I don't
like yeah absolutely yeah look it's it's
a very very good point the thing that I
always struggle with this issue and this
is someone who was a teacher for many
years and I taught autistic kids
is that no one picked up the link
between Autism and especially autistic
goals I think the the number though or
the stat that I get keep remembering is
40 of these girls who were referred had
autism and they were dealing with mental
health professionals why did someone not
jump on this sooner and go hang on
there's a very real link here between
Autism gender dysphoria then something
else is happening here do you see what I
mean well I think they did spot that so
I mean their own research showed that I
think it's 35 of of of boys and girls
that were referred had autistic traits
so they they spotted that and it's what
you do with it
and seemingly
it didn't change anything
and this is this is another theme if you
like that whether it's
that that you realize that over a third
of your referrals are autistic compared
to one two percent nationally whether
it's
new knowledge on
surgery whether it's new knowledge on
how the blocker might be working
clinicians use this phrase like
everything changed
but nothing changed
so practice just never changed so they
knew that they knew and the CQC picked
up that I think of the sample of records
that they looked at 50 were autistic
of the ones that have been referred for
the blockers but they weren't collecting
that data and when Kira Bell who was
seen at Jed's and transitioned and is
now detransitioned
when she took the case to the high court
in the original judgment the judges
remarked that they were surprised in
characteristically understated British
language that that
jizz didn't have that data how many of
the people you refer autistic they
didn't know
hey KK do you like trigonometry of
course I do incredible interviews
fascinating guests phenomenal live shows
and hilarious raw streams in that case
you need to join our locals so you can
have access to even more brilliant
content that's right you get the chance
to win incredible prizes ask our
phenomenal guests your questions access
extra content and now the only place to
watch our Roars on catch up is on locals
our war shows still go out at 7pm UK
time 2 p.m Eastern as normal but if you
want to watch some after this time then
you're gonna need to sign up to our
locals Ross have now become too spicy to
stay on YouTube so they're only
available to watch back on our locals
page all you need to do to sign up is
click on the link below this video and
for just seven dollars a month you have
access to All of This brilliant content
seven dollars a month even for someone
of my persuasion that's a bargain see
fuel on locals
and it's it's also the element of how
many of these kids who are going through
this process
they're just gay they're just gay kids I
mean
whenever I you know because the show has
got quite big now I
the people who come up to me
I get quite a lot of gay men and gay
women wanting to talk to me about this
and I remember talking to this gay lady
makes me sound like I'm from the 1950s
when I say that but a few weeks ago and
we were talking about this and she
approached me we were having a nice
conversation and she just looked at me
and she went thank God that I'm in my
late 20s because if this had been around
when I was 12
I would have transitioned and I would
have screamed the house down until
you know there was medical intervention
because that's how upset it was at the
fact that I was gay or I am gay I think
this is the part of the story which
people particularly in
you know
liberal
metropolitan cities find the hardest to
accept
and certainly that's like the reaction
that I've had
to to the work like it just can't be
true you know and clinicians themselves
they would get young people coming in
and using these vile homophobic slurs
that you know that we had at school in
the I think we're probably a similar age
you know the 80s and 90s and
and hearing that I kind of I thought we
were done with that I thought it just
wasn't a thing anymore to
for people to think it's not okay to be
gay but it but it is and it's not me
saying that like every clinician I spoke
to said that so many of those young
people were same-sex attracted even
those that spoke really favorably about
the work edges and particularly the
girls and actually when
those clinicians who were gay themselves
raise those concerns they say they were
accused of being too close to the work
that they were seeing something that
wasn't there and what they've turned
around and says look they say look at
the data like it's really rubbish like
we don't have much of it but what we do
have absolutely bears that out
so jizz's data for every single young
person that was referred to them in 2012
of the ones they have data for which is
the sort of the older ones they didn't
ask the very young kids
uh what was it 90 percent
of the girls identified as either
same-sex attracted as well or bisexual
and eighty percent of the boys and then
a slightly more recent stats those come
down to about 70 and 60 respectively but
they're still incredibly High
so they're saying we weren't seeing
something that wasn't there and I've
spoken to young people themselves
there's a there's a case in the book
Harriet who said I was a lesbian and it
was so obvious I went into my kids
assessment and I talked about the first
relationship that I'd had with a girl
and I felt really ashamed about it
because she wouldn't talk to me in
public and I've never been attracted to
a boy and all that was ignored
so it's not
it
the data the personal experiences the
experiences the clinicians it it's there
and I have to stress that of the people
I spoke to for the book not all of whom
are named or quoted but collectively
they've worked with thousands of young
people directly sitting in a room like
we are now face to face it's not
it's just I don't think it's credible to
pretend that the overwhelming
number of people who might be
uh affected by by this um
are gay bisexual lesbian I mean and that
has always been the case so every study
we have in this field is quite rubbish
but all of them
highlighted that and when Domenico De
Chelly opened jids back in 89 he always
made that point
that of this of any group of kids some
would grow up to be trans
but there would be the minority the
majority wouldn't and the majority of
them would be gay
and somehow this gets lost over the
years even though it was in the clinical
presentations and even though their own
data showed them that
and it wasn't
I don't know it wasn't it was just not
seen as a thing like the gender identity
was what What mattered so I described it
as medical malpractice earlier and I I
appreciate your commitment to impassion
impartiality and it's very strong but if
I'm reading between the lines and you
don't have to commit to my way of saying
it but
this was a situation in which due to a
number of structural and other failures
autistic and gay children
who were overwhelmingly the majority of
the cases if you put those two
categories together were essentially
treated for autism and homosexuality
with
puberty blockers or in in some way is
that overstating it
um
I mean
treat homosexuals
well I wasn't there no no no I mean
that's what I'm saying yeah I mean with
mental health issues autism and
homosexuality were treated as if they
they need this medical intervention yeah
I mean several things one is like
everybody
clearly established established but yeah
that that was and that was discussed I
mean you know this and the medical
direct various people were told this you
know they would have discussions I mean
it wasn't that discussion was shut down
and they talked all the time the fact is
they just taught but nothing changed so
that was the problem but they would have
staff meetings and you know really
worried clinicians would say maybe we're
medicating gay kids maybe we're
medicating autistic kids
and if we are we're doing something
quite
um dangerous
and it was that those fears couldn't be
responded to adequately and that's why
ultimately people left
because they felt that
the risks weren't the risks in the work
being adequately acknowledged or
minimized even there will always be a
risk because every single clinician I've
spoken to said you could never tell for
sure who's going to benefit and who's
not but there are ways of minimizing
that and there are ways of
um and and they felt that that isn't
what was happening
um but yes I mean if you go right back
to where this started
with a team in the Netherlands
they acknowledge right right right at
the beginning that the risk of blocking
puberty earlier
pre-16 was that you would get something
which they referred to as rather
euphemistically as false positives I.E
in your attempts to help those who would
grow up to be trans adults you would
probably the risk was you would also
include people who had they not had
their puberty blocked earlier
would not have transitioned and would
have somehow come to either accept or
their distress would have been relieved
without physical interventions
and all the data suggests that those
false positives are most likely
gay lesbian and bisexual
people and Hannah one thing I wanted to
ask you as well is given the rapid
increase in the number of referrals over
the years and the decades as you
described where does that come from
because gay people have always existed
autistic people have always existed how
do we get from a handful to thousands
that's a 64 million dollar question
isn't it I think there are lots of
so there are clinicians who are much
better at um hypothesizing about that
than I am so I'll just steal their ideas
but
um I think there are lots of reasons
and I was talking to someone recently
said oh it's either social contagion or
it's
uh greater social acceptance I don't
think that I think it's both and so I
think
I think for some people and I've spoken
to them I think greater visibility of
trans people and more social acceptance
I think that probably was the case for
them and I think there will be different
things for different people but I spoke
to people in the book who are like I
always felt this way
but I didn't know what it was called
and it's not for me to question their
story I think for some people it's
absolutely uh
whether we use the word contagion or not
but there's certainly influence of
friends and peer groups and even wpath
the world profession professional
association for transgender healthcare
acknowledges that in their most recent
standards of care that for some there
will be that influence because why
wouldn't there be there is for
everything
like we've all been teenagers and again
I've spoken to people for whom that was
definitely a factor where all their
group of friends were either trans or
non-binary and it was trendy and made
them fit in
think for the girls in particular
there are additional factors I think
right now it's really quite tough to be
a teenage girl we live in this quite
hyper-sexualized
world uh two jigs clinicians Anna
Hutchinson and Melissa midgen call it
the pornification you know this and
pinkification
and I think if I think for some young
women
if they don't feel that they are
or present in a way that is seen as
typically Uber feminine whatever that
means it's nonsense then
you can look for another way that
explains why you feel that you don't fit
in I think for some people
even for those for whom transition
hasn't worked most of them will say that
it did for a Time
and initially
in the early stages they felt great
because it was like oh this explains
this explains why I've been unhappy
um if you inject me with testosterone
I'll probably feel great for a while as
well so it's a natural antidepressant
that's what I mean right so so when you
inject people with drugs they often feel
great this is not necessarily yeah
and as we've discussed like internalized
homophobia we'll explain it for other
people so I think I think there are all
kinds of reasons can you put some
percentages on those things for us
because well the difficulty is that I I
agree with you that there's a complex
range of explanations but the problem is
that can be used and I'm not I'm not for
a second suggesting that's what you're
trying to do at all I'm just trying to
get to the truth here that can be a way
to conceal the reality of what's
Happening do you see what I'm saying
because if we say look there's a reason
for this that this is this but like one
of them is 90 of the entire time yeah
but I'll put it back to you like how
could we possible simply come up with
the percentages I mean what would that
look like how would we arrive at that
data I think it's hard to say one of the
things I think we
ought to look at is I don't know if
there's this has been done but several
years down the line you go and speak to
those people and see how they feel about
what happened yeah and then you kind of
break it down from there at the very
least we probably would want to know how
many people receive treatment that they
shouldn't have received that seems to me
quite a priority here yeah that'll be
good to know wouldn't it but we don't
know and why not
well I think there are several reasons
we don't know so one is
if we keep it focused on on
jeds
I I think they haven't wanted to find
out they haven't found out I mean
their own documents their own
information they've released under
Freedom of Information shows that there
was a time when they said yes we are
going to record both those who change
their minds prior to medication and
those who do once they've started either
the blocker or hormones and for a couple
of years 2017-18 they said yep we're
doing that and then they said suddenly
said no we're not going to do that it's
really time consuming so they never
collected that data
only they will know why because that
seems quite important data to have
because you
in order to benefit
it it's why I find the argument that
some people make that we shouldn't talk
about you know that talk of D transition
so people have gone through a medical
transition or surgical transition and
then revert back to their natal sex
that doesn't undermine the experience of
those
for whom a medical transition might work
actually I've spoken to you know there's
a there's a trans researcher in Canada
who's doing loads of research on
detransition and he says
we can make treatment better for
everybody if we understand those for
whom it doesn't work as well that's
equally important
because everybody wants to prevent that
happening
so yeah but we've had no follow-up of
jid's patients
so we don't know where they are we don't
know
who's happy who's unhappy who's
medically transitioned who hasn't and it
would be equally helpful to know
of those who never transitioned
what was it for them that
that worked or didn't work I mean these
are all really important questions which
we have no answers to
um what we do know from the very limited
studies that exist on people who have
de-transitioned is that the reasons they
give for
detransitioning and also identifying as
Trans in the first place they vary but
in how you ever get to Reliable
percentages I I just don't know yeah I
guess the reason I'm asking you is
again not trying to put anything on you
but
if I'm an ordinary person watching this
based on every time we've gone down one
of these cul-de-sacs we always end up
with there was not enough data they
stopped collecting it I'm thinking
cover-up
that's what I'm hearing now that is
quite I mean I watched Chernobyl the
other day you kind of see elements of
how people particularly in stressful
situations where there's a lot of fear
uh where they know they've done
something wrong but they don't want to
admit it you kind of can see how even
often well-meaning people will end up
doing things that that are bad and then
not wanting those things to be revealed
but it's just it sort of feels like
every time we go down one of these paths
we always end up where they stopped
collecting the data they stopped didn't
look into it they didn't want to know
this
that's sort of what it feels like here
to me
a
it it may be I I I I I don't know I mean
I I would I
one of the people I spoke to with the
book Dr Juliet singer so she's a child
Nellis and psychiatrist she also
happened to be a a governor at the
Tavistock
and she felt she was constantly asking
for data as soon as she arrived
and
she felt and certainly others feel that
it wasn't just that it wasn't a priority
which is strange in a clinical service
but it wasn't just that it wasn't she
she felt that they didn't want to find
out and that might be the case only they
will know for sure
um
but she also made the point that if you
don't have the data if you don't know
your patient population you don't know
how many are Autistic or
or gay or
you know have anxiety depression if you
don't know that you don't know the
long-term outcomes of the treatment you
don't know how many people are satisfied
or unsatisfied by the treatment how can
you be experts because what are you
experts in
now those are questions posed by people
who work at the trust
I don't you know it won't surprise to
say I'm not going to say it's a cover-up
but certainly the question has been
raised by those who are close to it and
just finishing off with these d
transitioners
their bodies have been irreversibly
changed
what are they experiencing what what and
what physical state are they left in now
as a result of these puberty blockers
the surgeries the hormones
do we know
I think different people are in
different situations so
a young
I mean your body from puberty blockers
that's not you're not going to be
permanently altered but what I would say
is that I'm still in touch with them a
young still identifies as trans a young
trans man he's 20 now so he was on
blockers for four years between the ages
of 12 and 16.
and he's chosen not to take testosterone
but
still identifies as male now
he broke four bones while on the blocker
and the talk that it's physically
completely reversible well do we know
that because so few people come off the
blocker that we don't really know and
when he came off the blocker no one from
either uclh or the Tavistock ever
followed up on him so he came off at 16.
it wasn't until 18 two years later that
he got his periods
and even now another two years later
they're not regular
he feels left behind I suppose
cognitively and emotionally from his
peers is that to do with the blocker we
don't know there's no there are no
studies there's no follow-up
so we don't know in terms of D trans d
transitioners
I think people handle it in different
ways I mean Harriet who I spoke to for
the book
um when I caught up with her again
recently after it was published she's
actually doing really well which is
great and she's much happier
um
you know she lives
with
her voice being a lot lower and
obviously sounding masculine and she's
had a double mastectomy but
um but I think there are also I think
talk of detransition actually masks lots
of things as well because
there are what does it mean like there
are people who've fully surgically
transitioned who have had what people in
the trans Community would call you know
both Top surgery and bottom surgery they
fully surgically transitioned now
and and some and I can't put any numbers
on it some are really unhappy like
desperately unhappy and given the chance
again they would not have done this can
they de-transition absolutely not
because
what would that look like your the body
has been totally changed by
hormones if you've had a hysterectomy
and you're female you're going to have
to you know you're gonna have to take
some kind of hormone all the time and if
you've fiddly surgically transition it
doesn't matter how you feel in and of
yourself Society will never perceive you
as your birth sex again that's just a
that's just a sad reality so in a way
detransition it
it's all a bit more complicated isn't it
well and how do you measure it uh
absolutely Hannah we could talk for
hours more and we will on our locals
with questions from our supporters but
for now I'll just remind everybody the
book is time to think uh thank you for
writing it before we head on over to
locals uh two things we'll ask you our
last question the other thing I should
say as well is
um I I know that this is not an easy
issue to cover uh mainstream news
non-mainstream news whatever so well
done for writing this thank you I know
and I can you know as as I've alluded to
repeatedly I can see it's not an easy
thing to have done necessarily but it is
an important one so time to think I hope
everybody reads it what's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society
that we should be
the standard of maternity care
tell us more
I think
you've gone BBC mode again no I haven't
I'm actually I'm actually thinking
[Laughter]
um
I think when you have one of the most
developed nations in the world and you
know close to 40 of maternity trusts are
inadequate or requiring Improvement I
don't think that's a good place to be
for women and their partners and their
children
agreed uh head on over to locals where
we continue the conversation
what would you say to people uh who may
be watching from other countries about
uh you know how these things ought to be
looked at or handled what is the right
approach
[Music]
thank you